JENNY MURPHY: Hi, Jenny here
from the Glass Developer
Relations team.
And I'm going to show you how
to get started with PHP and
the Mirror API.
So I'm going to show you the
easiest way to get started is
with a quick start project.
So you can see we have a bunch
of different quick start
projects in several different
languages.
But today, we're
interested PHP.
So let's click here.
You may be interested
to know what you're
getting yourself into.
So let's take a look at a demo
instance we have, in this
case, written in Java.
So we'll click on this
link and open it up.
This gives you an idea of what
to expect from one of these
quick starts.
You can see that it gives you
a foundation from which you
can build on top of, and build
your software quickly, and not
worry about all that
boilerplate code.
It also demonstrates a few
common patterns we expect you
to use in your Glassware,
sending a timeline card with
an attachment, spending timeline
items to all of your
users, managing contacts and
subscriptions, stuff like that.
OK, let's see how to
get you started.
First thing we're going
to want to do is
download the code.
We're going to click on this
big link that'll take us to
GitHub, where we can click the
download zip button and
download the project.
Let's switch over to our
terminal and let's start
setting it up.
So we're going to go
into downloads and
unzip what we have.
So we unzip the zip.
File It's going to
extract into a
directory, which we'll enter.
And there's a bunch
of files in there.
But we only care about one,
the config.php file.
So let's open up
a text editor.
And take a look at
what's in there.
This is the file we're
going to modify
the set up the project.
There are a few different
parameters that we're going to
set, the API information, which
we're going to get from
the API's console, a base URL
that tells our project where
it is on our system which
depends a lot on your system
configuration, and then finally,
a place for it to
store temporary data.
Let's get started with API
client configuration.
We have three values and we're
going to get them from the
Google API console.
So we'll switch back over
to our browser.
You can find the Google
API console at
code.google.com/APIs/console.
I've created a new project
for us to start with.
But if you've entered this
console and you don't have a
project, it's your first time
there, it's going to create a
project for you.
So the first thing that we're
going to want to do is turn on
the API from the services tab.
So we're going to scroll on down
to the Google Mirror API,
right down here.
And we're going to
click the toggle.
This may bring up developer
terms, which you'll probably
want to agree with
to use the API.
Now that it's enabled, we can
go up and scroll back up and
set up API access.
So click on API access to
bring up this new panel.
Then click on the inviting,
large blue button.
It's going to ask some questions
about the project
we're installing.
So Awesome Projects,
spelt right.
And then it's going to have some
more questions about how
our project is set up.
Mirror API software is usually
in the form of a web
application and so is
this quick start.
So we're going to leave the
top set to default.
Down below, we need to tell it
where we're going to run it.
We're going to start by running
it on our laptop, on
local host.
So we're going to want to turn
off HTTPS and tell it running
at local host.
And then whatever the directory
is that you're going
to be putting it on
your local system.
In my case, a directory
called web.
And then the PHP quick
start has a php file
for the OAuth callback.
So authtocallback.php,
click the Enter.
And then click Create
Client ID.
This is going to set up all of
our settings for the project.
If things are set up correctly,
you should see the
URL to the web directory your
have available followed by
[? oauthtocall.php. ?]
Now we just need a copy
some entries from this
page into our file.
So first we're going to start
with the client ID.
So we're going to copy that.
Come back on over.
And we're going to paste it
in here for API client ID.
Then we're going to grab
our client secret.
It's just two lines below
on the webpage.
A simple API key, which is down
in a box just below, down
here, under simple API access.
And then next, we're going to
configure the base URL.
As I mentioned, I'm running in a
different directory than the
default value is here.
So let's change this to /web.
And then finally, the
SQLite database.
The quick start uses SQLite to
persist data, which you'll
probably want to change if
you actually deploy it.
But it's a great way
to get started.
You can just put a file here
that's any place the web
server can write to.
I just chose /temp because it's
writeable by web servers
in most installations.
But this'll vary based on
your configuration.
So let's save that file.
And next, we'll either set up
a symlink, or move, or just
somehow get all the stuff into
that web accessible directory.
This is another thing
that's going to
depend on your system.
Maybe you want to set up a
symlink, copy it over.
In my case, I'm just
going to move it.
So I'm going to move all those
files to that web directory
that I have set up, which
is accessible from
my local web server.
So it's all moved in.
Let's take a look
at what's there.
So back to the web browser.
I'm going to go to
localhost/web, that directory
I set up and we see the
authentication page for the
quick start project.
Clicking Accept completes the
OAuth dance and gives the
quick start project access
to my Glass, the one I'm
wearing right now.
And as message has already been
delivered to my Glass
welcoming me to the
PHP start project.
You can click on these buttons
and it'll do more stuff.
In this case, I'm inserting
a picture of Chipotle, our
friendly cat.
And it was delivered.
And that's as simple
as it is to set up.
Now you can build software
on top of this.
You can modify these functions
and copy and paste.
And just to get going on
whatever you want to build.
And that's that.
Thanks very much for downloading
and running the
PHP quick start project.
We really look forward to seeing
what you come up with.